see psychic the heart of your system
[Music]
I'm near would have a kick guru AMD has
released a new graphics chip called rx
590 in this instance manifested in a
sapphire Nitro+ sample they don't appear
to be reference designs for this card it
seems to be down to the board partners
such as sapphire and that card there
does indeed seem very similar to the 580
in terms of its size and the cooling
system and suchlike there are a couple
of tweaks because it's a special edition
versions it has a dual BIOS function and
a flick switch but putting that to one
side rx 590 and when I say new it is
indeed based on rx 580 internal factors
are die shrink take the 580 which is 14
nanometer shrink it to 12 nanometer you
gain 200 megahertz almost exactly on the
base clock speed of the GPU and also the
boost speed in other respects such as
the memory controller type of memory
number of shaders all that sort of thing
it's exactly the same as the 580 this is
down to the buy shrink and the change in
speeds
it so happens AMD saying nothing
whatsoever about the 12 nanometer
process we are kind of assuming that
it's a glow flow process rather than
TSMC that is not for sure so the changes
that have been made
AMD is currently saying nothing although
I have a sapphire card in front of me
this launch is being handled by AMD they
are not giving out technical details
about the actual chip itself so we're
shifting from Polaris 20 to Polaris 30
RX 580 to RX 590 and this of course late
in 2018 and you might wonder why the
heck ambi is bringing out a revision of
a relatively elderly graphics card and
there's a very good reason for it which
is the vast over half of the gaming
market games at 1080p which is gtx 1060
territory now gtx 1060 is going to cost
you about 250 pounds about the same as
an RX 580 and then you have a hefty step
up to GTX 1070 there you talk about 400
pounds or so and there's just a gap in
that market that gap is intended to be
filled by RX 590 my test setup consists
of an Intel Core i7 8700 K that is
obviously six core coffee
4.4 gigahertz all-cause motherboard is
gigabyte z3 17 horas Ultra gaming I've
got some matching horas RGB digital 430
200 megahertz memory as it happens that
module there is a dummy just carries
lights that's a real module that's a
dummy just carries lights and that is a
real module I'm due to do a review of
that quite soon so you've got four
things that look like modules would
actually two of them are just the light
units these CPU cooler is a fractal
designs Celsius s 24 that's a 240 ml a
stick SSDs one terabyte Dali D black
that's name not to just above the
graphics card and the power supply see
Sonic prime platinum 1300 watt it is
worth pointing out that this is my own
test setup it is similar to one dominant
uses however he's out of action for a
few days which is why I'm doing this
graphics card launch so my figures
cannot be directly compared to Dominic's
however they are certainly in the
correct ballpark obviously I'm also
using latest drivers so again points of
differentiation but the figures in the
test charts are my own and I wouldn't
want to mix up figures from two
different systems done at two different
times and what we are comparing is the
rx 518 nitro pass from sapphire which I
found will sell at 230 pounds that's 250
US dollars dollars pounds very similar
these days the RX 590 we've been told
should be two seven nine dollars
fractionally more so I'm calling that
250 pounds now that immediately makes
you wonder whether that 230 pound or x58
is going to drop in price common sense
would say so how far who knows but it
doesn't seem likely to me the 580 could
exist at 2:30 and then the 590 come
along at 250 it just seems too close
together then we have a gtx 1060
founders edition that's a six gigabyte
model that's 240 pounds at the moment
gtx 1070 fans edition 8 gig
that's a 420 and a vega 56 which is
currently 450 pounds it i shouldn't need
to say this but we all know that in
recent months past year
on four GPUs has been all over the place
and therefore what manufacturers say
about reference pricing and availability
and so on it you use it have to look at
what is actually the state to play in
any given week to see what prices are so
the RX 580 and gtx 1060 are very close
together the vega 56 and the gtx 1070
are also very close together and then
the 590 is slightly above this 580 at
the moment as i say doesn't quite make
sense in terms of pricing question
obvious is how do these all perform
relative to each other
[Music]
few points worth noting before we get in
the actual benchmark results so one is
that the two Nitro+ cards have a zero
fan feature when they're idling they sit
there that the fans rotating nice and
quiet but obviously that means that the
idle temps can appear a tad high if you
want you can turn the fans on but that
of course makes noise and we like quiet
things
second thing is overclocking GPU voltage
you can simply bang up the slider to the
max plus 200 millivolt you can bang up
the power limit plus 20% and then you
can start turning up the GPU clock and
if you want you can punch in a number
directly for example and similarly the
memory if you want go crazy and happy
days and then you apply and off you go
we found during our testing with the RX
580 Nitro+ that you could actually crank
up the figures endlessly at a certain
point it wouldn't crash it would simply
give you slower results because it was
throttling rx 590 was much more for
nikah t overclocking if you bump up the
power limit and increase the GPU voltage
by a small amount that's gone far too
far like 20 millivolts of pit we've
added its limit increase the core speed
to a mere 1600 and that was about as
good as it got for us now it could be
the next version of tricks will behave
more nicely but this feels very much
like rising 7 second gen and indeed
second gen thread Ripper which is that
the GPU is being intelligently managed
it's a trade-off of power temperature
and speed and it handles it all very
nicely but our experience was that out
of the box rx 590 in the case of the
Sapphire Nitro+ the performance you get
is that that's it
overclocking there are tiny benefits to
be gained
AMD states that the 12 nanometer
technology they use
the RX 590 gives you up to 15%
improvement in clock speeds and up to
12% increase in performance absolutely
correct an actual fact when you're
comparing Nitro+ with Nitro+ RX 580 or
it's 590 you're looking at 10 percent
improvement in clock speeds and about 10
percent improvements in the performance
which is absolutely great
what great might be overstating it but
it's absolutely satisfaction it's
certainly there or there abouts compared
to a M these claims and how does this
manifest itself in the real world
obviously it depends what you're doing
if you stick to 1080p gaming then the RX
580 and the GTX 1060 the models that we
have are pretty much inseparable now
we've got a nitro plus rx 580 we've got
a Founders edition 1060 so you can argue
the toss there possibly but that's a
very good comparison for us the 590 add
10% it is better than a 10 60 is it as
good as the 1070 that depends really
does depend if you're one of these I
want a game at 1080 never 144 Hertz
monitor possibly not on the other hand
if you're gaming at a lower refresh rate
anything above 60 as far as I'm
concerned makes for a decent gaming
experience but some of you want 120 144
hurts
in which case fair enough nonetheless it
does deliver decent performance certain
games for example Middle Earth shadow of
war if you move for 1062 a 1070 the
difference in performance is absolutely
minimal whereas if you step up from the
RX 580 TRX by 90 you do get a benefit
you do get some curious results like
that whereas if you go to far cry 5 the
results in our graphs are absolutely
crystal-clear there is a clear benefit
to be gained by stepping up in graphics
power funnily enough it's the synthetic
tests such as 3d marks various fire
strikes and x plus and suchlike
where you can you look at the graphics
cause obviously role in the overall
score but how much benefit you see
there's a minimal difference frankly
between the RX 518 the RX 590 gameplay
the difference is more pronounced now
when you consider that in video has long
had a massive clock speed advantage over
MD but fewer shaders higher clock speed
performance result and
we know the benefit they've had with rx
590 the clock speed the gap is closed by
that 200 megahertz and it does make a
difference not clearly if they're
running at 2 gigahertz we'd love to see
that no two ways about it but 1600 is
better than 1400 that is an absolute
fact
so overall and we finished overall the
RX 590 particularly those rx 598 we seen
from sapphire the Nitro plus it's a
decent graphics card we're happy with it
we are happy to the 580 however this is
just an extra 10% so what's going to
make the big difference for us probably
is going to be pricing let's assume now
the mining craze or whatever it is
boomers is overall site at least reduced
let's assume that availability is going
to be back to somewhere same then
pricing is going to be the thing if it
means the 580 comes down in price you
can get a 585 you know a decent chunk
less than a 1060 well that would be nice
if on the other hand Amy's going to try
and charge a premium for a slot between
1060 and 1070 and above 580 for the 590
they're going to kind of create a new
niche for it that could be difficult
that really could so we're gonna have to
wait and see exactly what happens with
pricing it's it seems unlikely that it's
gonna make sense to have a 250 pound
graphics card and a 230 pound graphics
card those would just appear to be too
close for comfort
so asked whether the 590 goes up or the
580 comes down and how exactly that
works out we're gonna have to wait and
see we don't expect that there will be
any four gigabyte versions of this
graphics card eight gigabytes is gonna
be the thing they don't appear to a new
reference versions partner cards only
so this nitro plus is not to our mind a
premium version of rx 590 it is a
typical rx 590 and that in itself is
welcome it's got a back plate it's
quality it's got a proper cooler
temperatures really nice throughout it's
now sitting there with a fan idling fans
idling lovely and quiet so there's a lot
to be said for this new launch and in
many respects is the details that make
the difference rather than me you got an
extra 10% be interesting to find out at
some point what has actually happened in
terms of the fabrication process and
such like
that really is a detail I don't think
there's any reason why the paying
customer should particularly care about
the fabrication process or the number of
transistors or the die area whatever
transistors and Dyer being the same as
580 but the the process shouldn't matter
the question is how does it work what
are the temperatures what's the power
draw like what's the performance like
and as you'll see in our charts the
answers are good good good as to why
it's taken them quite so long to come up
with a 12 nanometer version of the
previous 40 nanometer GPU goodness alone
those you could almost believe that
they're actually looking what in video
is doing and saw that Nvidia have
brought out the was going to bring out
the 2080 the 2070 and they're going to
do something with 2060 and at the moment
there is indeed this this chasm for
1080p gamers and this graphics card
would appear to step very neatly into
that open market and we have to welcome
that if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up do look around find the Bell
button mash the Bell button and you'll
be notified about new videos as it
become available
I'm your diffic Gary this is the
Sapphire Nitro+ RX 590 which is the
sample that we have of AMD's new rx 590
[Music]